nó mướt nó mịn nó mềm gì đâu cả nhà ơi
bỏ có vài trăm mà hốt được
combo 4 món chăn GA gối phi lụa chuẩn
web homestay hạng sang
hè này nằm là thấy mát liền
đặc biệt chăn còn có sẵn chần bông
mùa nóng mà còn nằm mấy bộ cotton giày là xác định nóng hầm
bí lưng xoay người là giết dịch khó chịu
muốn đổi qua bộ xịn hơn thì nhìn giá xịn chịu lại hơi trùn
Tay nhưng giờ thì không cần lăn tăn nữa
chỉ tầm BA 2 là có ngay full
combo 4 món chăn GA 2 vỏ gối lụa Thái
bề mặt phải mướt mịn chạm vào là thấy mát nhẹ
nằm lâu vẫn thoáng không bị bí hay dính mồ hôi
kiểu nằm xuống là dính luôn
điểm cộng lớn là chăn đã có sẵn chần bông
dùng được quanh năm không cần mua thêm
kích thước rộng rãi tới 2m X 2m³
nằm thoải mái Cho cả gia đình
họa tiết in nhiệt 6 D sắc nét màu lên nhìn sang xịn
giặt không lo phai 2 loang
vải cũng ít nhăn nhanh khô nên dùng rất tiện
một bộ vừa đẹp vừa mát
vừa nâng vai phòng ngủ mà giá chỉ vài trăm
bảo SAO hội mê decor chốt đơn dần dần
hè này mà chưa đổi qua phi lụa là hơi thiệt rồi